tens of thousands of protesters traveled
from across the country Gathering
outside Israel's parliament the knesset
for a sixth week to demonstrate against
controversial judicial reform plans
many believing the new right-wing
Coalition government's decisions will
steer the country away from democratic
values and the rule of law
everything for my children and
processing for this country and
protesting for the country my father
fought for my brother fought for my
uncle died for
echoing that sentiment is opposition
leader and former prime minister yai
lapid
we will not hide in the houses as they
try to turn Israel into a dark dictation
they will not shut us up
the reforms would allow the knesset to
religious
and influence the appointments of judges
well we've seen people from all sectors
of society here teachers artists dancers
people from the lgbtq community and the
tech industry as well but they're all
here with the same message they say
they're concerned about the future of
this country
the danger is is that the the the
Supreme Court would lose his
independence and will not know
while we were filming things got heated
as we'd seen a few times between
protesters and government supporters
the scenes weren't much different inside
the Parliament building
[Music]
salts were exchanged between the ruling
party and opposition members after
several hours of deliberation a
committee approved the Judiciary reform
Bill's progress to be voted on in
Parliament in the coming days
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu says
the proposed changes are needed to reign
in an already powerful Judiciary his
supporters have also dismissed the
protests as a refusal to accept the
election result we said from the
beginning we want to negotiate we want
to have a wider support for the bill but
it takes two and I hope that the
opposition some of the parts of the
opposition are cannot acknowledge the
fact that they lost the election
Israeli president Isaac Herzog and his
U.S counterpart Joe Biden have urged
both sides to come together and build a
consensus so far there appears to be
little room for negotiation
the next few days though will prove
vital
Al Jazeera West Jerusalem